so larry uh yes larry okay so we got  this brand new late night show  coming to peacock where we're finally  gonna have  those conversations that america says  they want to have right now about  time completely title for our new late  night show  go okay oh so you're finally ready to  talk about race  blurry bit on the nose i'll stop talking  when it stops happening with larry  wilmore huh  you actually think you're gonna stop  talking what the did he just say with  larry wilmore  not very peacocky no no no no no no what  the hell is going on  with larry wilmore well i mean it  doesn't not work  and i'm getting told for this with larry  one more  yes yes let me try that one on you like  that huh  actually the show's just called wilmore  a brand new late night special series  new episodes every friday stream for  free um peacock  i feel like i was about to right i don't  know man we're just i could tell  it looked like you were gonna say it did  wow that was good  you